what's up guys bang bang this was an
absolutely ridiculous week in the
bitcoin market there's all kinds of
chaos fear and uncertainty flying around
so let's dig right into these metrics
and see what the hell has happened in
the past seven days
all right so obviously this week was
absolutely insane but bitcoin recovering
nicely sitting right around thirty
thousand dollars you can see that it's
trading right in tandem with many other
assets if we then go and we look at the
bitcoin statistics themselves bitcoin
market cap sitting just under 600
billion dollars still about 1.77
inflation rate and of course over 90 of
the 21 million bitcoin have actually
been issued the real exchange volume
coming down drastically under 4 billion
dollars now but miners they continue to
get paid to secure the decentralized
secure computing network of bitcoin but
now they're only being paid 27 million
dollars every 24 hours bitcoin is traded
down 56 from its all-time high but it's
up about 15 from the recent low if we
then go and we take a look at bitcoin
versus gold and the s p 500 we can see
that over a one year period bitcoin down
significantly 40
gold down one and s p 500 down two but
if you zoom out and look over a two to
ten year period bitcoin has drastically
outperformed gold and snp on almost any
other timeline and then of course paying
attention to bitcoin's closing price
history we can see that bitcoin trading
right around thirty thousand dollars
means that there's only been about 487
days in its history which traded higher
than this and so if you bought bitcoin
and held on ninety percent of days until
today you would be in the money but
still nine point nine eight percent of
the time it was actually trading higher
than it has been today if we then go and
take a look we can see that the
compounding yield growth rate of bitcoin
is 138 still drastically outperforming
gold s p 500 nasdaq and tlt and then
that five year sharp ratio coming in at
1.26
still making an attractive way to add to
your portfolio and have a positive
impact let's jump now and go take a look
at will clemente the blockwear team got
an excellent newsletter that they put
out every friday and then this week
they've got some great charts first we
have the net realized profit and loss we
can see that about 2.5 billion dollars
in net realized losses on two separate
days just this past week now if we jump
and we look at what's causing all these
problems everyone knows that luna and
terra ecosystem has had major major
issues including their altcoin going
literally to zero and the ust stablecoin
losing its peg you can see that this
luna foundation card balance of bitcoin
was growing nicely it was holding price
up all of a sudden this dropped and
basically they have no bitcoin left now
that's resulted in some of the largest
days of net bitcoin inflows to exchanges
in nearly five years which blockwear and
will have identified nicely you see it
here in green on the far right of this
chart then we can go take a look at
whale balances and we see that whale
balances continue to decline which is a
theme that is going to be important
watch as we move forward then of course
the short-term holder cost basis we're
trading underneath it and we've gotten
rejected off of that a couple of times
and it continues to go deeper and deeper
that means that of course the short-term
holders they're in trouble then if we go
ahead and we take a look at realized
price we can look at something like a
top or bottom model we can see that
those realized price we're getting close
but the aggregated cost basis of all
investors on chain currently sits around
twenty four thousand dollars and so any
price below the realized price should be
seen as extreme value now let's jump to
the mv rv z score and that compares
bitcoin's market value to the realized
value and in that we can see in this
green zone we're getting close to a
generation buying opportunity and so
then if we jump to something like the
entity adjusted dormancy flow we see
here we're in the green it's flashing a
buy signal then jump to the reserve risk
again this is measures hauler confidence
in comparison to price and we're
flashing a buy signal there as well if
we go look at something like the mayor
multiple it's been around for quite a
while that's the comparison of the price
relative the 200-day moving average
again one of the lowest points in
bitcoin history and flashing a buy
signal and then of course bitcoin
approaching that 200 week moving average
currently sitting at 22 000 as we get
closer and closer to that it only means
that more and more people are going to
say bitcoin may be valued at a point
that is quite attractive and so
ultimately if you're able to get the
courage conviction and have the dry
power you buy around these points
there's no guarantee of future
performance but it sure has in the past
worked out pretty well next i want to
jump over and look at dylan leclair he
had a great tweet where he pointed out
the reserve risk is quantifying that
huddler conviction relative to price we
can see that deep buy signal flashing
there as well
and then lastly dylan had a great tweet
where he basically summarized what's
happening right now everyone wants to
buy blood until it actually comes this
is part of what makes this current
market so unique is that everybody prays
for a lower bitcoin price if they're
trying to accumulate more and more but
now that it's here there's tons of fear
uncertainty and chaos in the market
you need to do your own research you
need to be aware of the risk but as
we've seen in chart after chart after
chart and metric after metric there are
buy signals flashing all over the place
all right that's it for this week hope
you guys are enjoying this make sure you
subscribe to the channel like this video
and next week i'll be back in studio
with will clemente joining us and let's
all just hope that the market's a little
bit calmer until then i'll see you guys
on the internet